what I have here is a line and I have a
point that is not on that line and my
goal is to draw a new line that goes
through this point and is perpendicular
to my original line how do I do that
well you might imagine that our compass
will come in handy it's been handy
before and so what I will do is I'll
pick an arbitrary point on our original
line let's say at this point right over
here and then I'll adjust my compass so
the distance between the pivot point and
my pencil tip is the same as the
distance between those two points and
then I can now use my compass to trace
out an arc of that radius there you go
now my next step is to find another
point on my original line that has the
same distance from that point that is
off the line and I can do that by
centering my compass on that off line
point and then drawing another arc and I
can see very clearly that this point
also has the same distance from this
point up here and then I can Center my
compass on that point and notice I
haven't changed the radius of my compass
to draw another arc like this to draw
another arc like this and then what I
can do is connect this point and that
point and it at least looks
perpendicular but we're going to prove
to ourselves that it is indeed
perpendicular to our original line so
let me just try so you have that like
that so how do we feel good that this
new line that I just drew is
perpendicular to our original one
well let's connect the dots that we made
so if we connect all the dots we're
going to get a rhombus we know that this
distance this distance is the same as
this distance the same as this one right
over here which is the same as this
distance
let me make sure I get my straightedge
right same as that distance which is the
same as this distance same as that
distance and then so this is a rhombus
and we now know that the diagonals of a
rhombus intersect at right angles so
there you have it I have drawn a new
line that goes through that offline
point and is perpendicular to our
original line